all right YouTube we're live we're going
old school today I'm doing something
that I've only done I think one time
before an interview via Google Hangouts
we've only done this once before we did
it right when I moved into this house
when we were building out the studio and
we didn't have a studio my first ever
interview with Jordan Peterson which was
the first time that I ever talked to
Jordan we did be a Google hangout
sitting in my my living room over there
yesterday I was supposed to have avi M&E
who is in that box right there who I'll
introduce to you in a second I was
supposed to have him right here in
studio for a normal show and he was on
his way a couple days ago from Australia
to the United States which is a freaking
long and neck I took I mean I took a 15
hour flight from I guess who was from
Sydney to to Texas couple weeks ago
after a five-hour flight I think from
Perth to Sydney or something like that I
mean it was like 30-something hours of
total travel anyway it's a long-ass
flight he tried to enter the United
States and he was denied entry now why
did it all this happen well I'm gonna
kick it to ah be right now I'll be first
off before we do anything else here for
any of my audience that does not know
who you are what's the best way to
describe you considers up a youtuber you
a provocateur you're sort of a quasi
20:19 journalist what do you consider
yourself well now I'm actually a
journalist for a freelance journalist I
work mostly with TR dot news I started
on a I wasn't business owner and I go by
the tag Israeli some Australian Israeli
proud of both love free Western Way of
life I kind of fell into this I was I
was a gym owner that ran Krav Maga
geum's and to be honest it was really
when one of the operations in Gaza kind
of kicked off and I was watching like
the mainstream media report on it and I
was getting so frustrated with their
reporting and I had really popular gyms
at the time
just started kind of commenting and and
writing what I experienced myself and
what I knew to be true from the ground
from someone who actually served on the
front line there and I guess it's kind
of started a conversation I lost a lot
of members at the time I also gained a
few but I guess after that I kind of
found a voice and I continued kind of
commenting on all sorts of political
issues and people kind of gave me some
constructive criticism people that are
like I trust so maybe don't use your
business page for that speaking and now
YouTube is a new thing for me to be
honest because before that I was a
hundred percent on Facebook until they
they kicked me off and apparently hate
speech which I don't believe I ever
engaging you know but obviously it's
very broad those terms so that's where I
am today Tommy Robinson who he's very
well-known obviously in the UK yeah and
I think Tommy we were trying to get him
in here and you know I interviewed him
once years ago on skype and I don't even
think he's allowed to come to the United
States either so you're you're in
company with people that can't get into
the good old United States okay so I
want you to tell exactly what happened
with Jim Jefferies and Comedy Central I
should preface this by saying that until
the clip that I saw of you which now has
millions and millions I think over 3
million views and on YouTube I have
never seen Jim Jefferies show I don't
really know who he is I know he's a
comedian but I don't really know who he
is so I have no you know dog in this
fight one way or another it's not like
I'm a fan of his or a hater of his I
don't really watch Comedy Central I
don't think anyone really watches Comedy
Central anymore I think pretty much
pretty much I think I know the last time
I watch Comedy Central was when when Jon
Stewart was still hosting The Daily Show
he had ayaan Hirsi Ali on and he threw
her under the bus and well I don't know
if you've seen it it was one of the most
disgusting interviews I've ever seen
it's really really awful and I pretty
much just tuned out a Comedy Central
then and you know I think since then
well I guess maybe I his Futurama is
still on there
well I've no idea I don't even watch it
to be honest to be honest in Jeffries is
an Aussie who who got famous in America
it wasn't he was kind of crappy yeah he
likes to drop the C bomb a lot I guess
in America you find that fascinating and
funny one thing I did like I was a fan
of his ones because he what he would
push the boundaries he was he wasn't
politically correct he would make jokes
about kind of anything but I think over
the last few years especially when it
comes to the gun debate he's found his
little place in Hollywood and even in
some of the clips that I released after
that or if you watch the whole clip you
can see I challenged him on it I call
him I was I tell him he's a he's a
sellout and he admits he admits it the
life in Hollywood is nice so you can't
really blame him for that part of it ok
yeah yeah so before we get too far ahead
though and I have no doubt that at the
Viacom building in New York City and in
LA right now there are plenty of
executives watching this so you could
talk you could talk directly to them and
you can talk directly to Jim I suspect
him is not gonna retweet this although I
did tag him in it but anyway I preface
it that way just to say I I Drive you
not blocked I know I'm sure I'll be back
soon enough
but I preface it that way just to say I
have nothing against the guy
specifically until I saw what happened
and now it's like this is just such the
reason I wanted to have you on was that
it's such a perfect example of fake news
of media manipulation the way that these
people often these media personalities
privately do one thing and publicly do
another I mean it's just and then really
to your credit that you were smart
enough to videotape the whole thing so
just start at the beginning how did you
even get on the Jim Jefferies show so
that he'd call me I think it was
December time I was in Israel I remember
correctly well maybe I was in in Europe
but it give me a call it said listen
Jim's the traveling Australia at the
moment he's he's right organizing he's
doing a tour in Australia but he was
running a special for
Netflix or one of one of these Comedy
Central specials and he was wondering if
I would be willing to come on to discuss
immigration to discuss the border wall
and I know Jim Jeffries and I know where
he stands or at least publicly where he
stands these days on issues and I'm not
I'm somebody that's confident in my
beliefs I have no problem
you know discussing anything with anyone
but I also know he's untrustworthy and
I've been involved in the media for long
enough to know that I need to set out
some conditions and I set up two basic
conditions one don't put me with
neo-nazis or anyone who believes Hitler
would do and two is just put my answers
to the questions that you ask me don't
cut it up it's a technique that they
love doing and you know I Street
interviews myself and I would never do
that to somebody because there's no
point that the whole idea is if somebody
is stupid
or if somebody answers something
ridiculous ridiculously you don't need
to cut it yeah I can actually just put
it out there and everybody the world is
there to judge yeah but that's kind of
the game these guys have been playing
for a long time right like I interned I
interned at the Daily Show back in 1999
it's a long freaking time ago and I
remember you know I don't know that they
were doing what he did with you which is
taking an answer to one question and
placing it to another but I always
remember thinking when they get these
local Republicans on and then mock them
the whole time it's like what were these
idiots thinking like you know you're
walking into the Daily Show man like you
know you're going to be selectively
edited or they're gonna put a pause on
it a weird way for a laugh or or just
some some level of manipulation so you
went out here way before just don't
expect it to be so bad like it to be
honest the last one I'd seen of Jim
Jefferies is what he did to Jordan
Peterson and I thought to myself you
know I look at someone like Jordan
Jordan Peterson and I look at him he's
an academic he's far smarter than me
and if Jim Jeffries could make him kind
of look like a dumbass then
obviously he's out to get me so and I
went to they flew me to Singapore I told
him the third issue is that I'm just not
in Australia at the moment so I'm happy
to do it if you if you agree to those
two conditions I'm happy to do it but
obviously it has to be the time and I
can it worked out that flew me to
Singapore pay for my hotel pay for all
my expenses it was great little trip I
walk in there and I knew I also spoke to
my good friend Tommy Robertson who's had
a lot of experience with fake news and
he agreed straightaway he said make sure
you've got footage of it so I went in
there and I thought I had two phones not
one but two phones are winning there
because I wanted to make sure in case
one collapse which it actually did
that's why if you look at the footage
some of it's blurry because one actually
recorded the whole thing and I walk in
there and I was thinking if they stopped
me and they you know they I started
recording from the moment I walked in
because I said if they stopped me I
didn't care at that point if they kicked
me out while I'm setting up my cameras
to film myself then that's my video show
that they're not even willing to engage
me without trying to screw me but nobody
noticed nobody noticed anything and I
set it up it was like it was couches and
I put these pillows there was it took me
a good minute and I went even went back
and reset it was you know that was so
self-absorbed
yeah they're so they're so fat on their
on their egos or their importance or
something now it was it was a couple of
months I think till I just held on to it
I didn't you know I could have put that
Mohammed stuff out straight away I could
but I thought you know what I'm going to
wait on an animal word I want to see how
this plays out and I was actually at a
poor him event so what is it a couple of
weeks ago and I didn't even know the the
segment had been released and some you
know a bud rabbi walks up to me goes I
saw your Jim Jeffries thing last night
they totally he screwed you or he I
think his wording was more like he
wrecked you like it was as if he even
Heba
leave the context of the on the
interview and that all the cuts were
actually true and I'm sitting there like
after a few you know pouring drinks and
I just opened up my phone and I'm just
watching I'm going I can't believe this
he's literally put me in the context of
Christ Church of the Christ Church
massacre with some crazy white
supremacist who hates my guts 100% he
believes that Jews should be in Israel
yeah he doesn't think Australia's a good
thing just to be just to be very clear
you tape the interview what a good two
three months before it was and I'm in
shock I'm saying that cut up Myers is in
twenty seconds of the the clip they have
the most prominent neo-nazi in Australia
they've cut up even my facial reaction
my expressions they took like especially
when he would say something bizarre and
I'd like you know cringe up my face he
he's taking that and cut it with you
know reasonable questions that he's us
and the best part was I got him saying
he will learn he can cut it up to make
himself look perfect so I and I just
myself I went and I said I told the bud
guy there the rabbi I said wait till
tomorrow you'll see you'll see the truth
then I went back in okay now what's odd
to me is I expected that once they see
that they would retract immediately
they'll apologize they will remove the
the defamatory content no they didn't do
any of that and they still haven't done
any of that in fact I managed to get
banned on YouTube it picked them I
managed to get banned within 24 hours
from posting that on Facebook Facebook
denies it has anything to do with that
but they won't give me any proof from
any other post that has that breached
their terms and conditions in fact I
didn't post anything for a good that
period besides for the Jim Jeffrey stuff
so I don't know what it possibly can be
right
okay so for the for the people that
haven't seen it so he splices answers
that you give to other questions to make
it seem like you're you're racist
basically radical I'm crazy and the fact
is if I watched that if I'd watch that I
don't like that guy oh yeah thank God
and that was what he was designed to do
was to make me look like a bad nut job
you know and he tried to he tried to
make it like he literally says in a the
only thing that could bring Jews and
white supremacists together is their
shared hate for Muslims you know
absolutely outrageous disgusting the
fact is that I've never shown hate from
Muslims ever in my life because I think
hating on a people is wrong as a Jew I
find that offensive to hate honor to
targeted people to criticize Islam I
always do it because I think any idea
should be you know tested tried and
tested and discussed but so what it
wasn't just though that he manipulated
what you said what you also caught him
saying off camera and this really to me
this is the beauty of it because I think
even if beforehand you said to them guys
don't sandbag me you know don't edit my
stuff and they promise to do all that
like I live in Hollywood I know how this
business works they're all liars and
frauds and they'll say anything and do
any of that but the the real I think the
real meat of this is what you caught him
saying because that really shows the 180
on reality so could you lay out some of
that say look Jim Jefferies used to say
a lot of that stuff publicly in in a lot
of his original shows lately
obviously he's he's become a very good
liberal lovey-dovey it's all about you
know and the thing is that segment that
specific segment was about pointing at
people like me and blaming us for
radicalizing people like that crazy
Christ Church killer he's gone in there
he's drawn Mohammed you know he's even
went as far as making it made a few
drugs and said how much you hate Islam
fine fair enough I actually have no
what'd he write and then especially in
the context of comedy I think it's fine
mm-hmm I just don't think you have the
right then to turn around and point
fingers at someone like me who would
never even say anything close to what he
said even as a joke in fact I had to
pull him up at one point where he was
joking about dingoes killing little
Muslim babies and vomiting which is not
even funny
yeah and now for those who are out there
who were claiming that he only said it
to bait me well no actually originally
he used to he used to be like he used to
say that publicly he's changed because
now that's where you know he's following
the money he obviously doesn't believe
anything he preaches he's two-faced is
exactly the definition of two-faced and
fake but also if he was trying to bait
you to do the baiting off-camera and
then your answers on time I mean that in
and of itself again this is not
surprising how these guys operate but
that would show you a little bit of the
motivations there absolutely he came in
with certain intentions and the thing is
he couldn't he didn't get the outcome he
wanted so the only way to produce it was
literally to reproduce it to cut it up
and anyone can look stupid when you do
that and anyone can look bad and you can
literally ruin someone's life you if I
didn't capture that my life would be
ruined there's no way for me to be able
to defend against any of what he's put
out there I still find it crazy that
till today they've not only not
responded they blocked and and banned
any you know a lot of people and you can
look you know some people aren't getting
back to you you and me so far not but if
you look at my Twitter there's posts up
that I keep retweeting of people just
bent and and for what they're saying is
literally can you at least face what
you've done Jim can can Comedy Central
make a statement can you do something
but nothing they're just blocking
they've actually restricted comments on
Instagram so that's what I think is so
interesting here because it's such a
perfect storm of all of the crap that
sort of I'm always talking about here
and what
with the media and then and then how
people individuals online are able to
fight back because right now if you look
at Comedy Central's Twitter feed or the
Jim Jefferies show specifically if you
look at air mentions it is no matter
what he tweets it's real people decent
human beings saying are you going to
address this and all that so before we
get to what happened when you tried to
get the United States to meet in the
studio yesterday if if Comedy Central
today or Jim Jefferies personally issued
an apology admitted the whole thing
which at which now everyone knows to be
true so it's not much about Mia culpa
because it's like yeah you're just
admitting what what blatantly is obvious
would you accept that and then just move
on from this situation
well well every day that passes the
bigger the apology is gonna have to be
the more the more the louder it's gonna
have to be because it now on their all
their social media platforms that
defamatory video has been up what is it
two weeks now they've been running it on
cable TV it's been everywhere so they've
kind of got to reach everyone they've
reached tuna now having said that I
think my video has reached more than
theirs but I don't know if it's the same
audience they need to really show that
they finally accept what they did and
that it was wrong and it is not you know
I've heard a lot of people turn around
and go oh but how can you take Comedy
Central serious after all it's called
Comedy Central but I don't accept that
because one it wasn't a joke what they
were discussing it wasn't a joke the
time that they were discussing it wasn't
a joke that they were pointing at me for
someone who was partly responsible in
making that happen it's not a joke to
cut somebody up I don't mind I make fun
of myself all day every day if you watch
my YouTube I like I had no problem doing
that but there are certain lines that
even I like I don't get offended easily
but I am frickin offended by the content
that they produced so yes in theory
people accept an apology
taking responsibility but it has to
match the amount they pushed the fight
news till now yeah and I don't even know
how they could do that at this point I
mean and you know it's so interesting
also because that's why I decided to do
a long-form interview show in the first
place years ago because I was like I'll
do these things we won't edit for
content I like doing them live you can
say whatever you want I can edit you and
ironically when I do what like when I
when I do television it's so funny cuz
Fox News is the only one that'll put me
on I was on Tucker last night but it's
live there's no chance that they're
gonna they could sandbag me you know ask
me something intentionally inflammatory
but it's all live and I just know I just
wouldn't go on these shows anymore that
would be for going what would you even
what would you even do it well there's
two things one is I knew I was gonna
record it so it was a win-win I was
gonna either get a good segment where I
actually got to reach an audience that I
wouldn't typically be able to reach and
have my say and present my opinions and
maybe change a few minds maybe not
whatever but at least be presented
properly or I'm gonna get to expose the
fake news and that's exactly what I did
and I'm gonna call it fake news even
though they are Comedy Central because
that is what they did and people come to
those shows to get the Newsies it's sad
it is sad but people come to those shows
to get their news and the fact is if
they presented as real news then it is
just the same it is all the same and
they have that platform they have that
responsibility well I completely agree
with that because you know remember when
when Jon Stewart was hosting The Daily
Show I mean I know no one watches it
anymore it's completely irrelevant but
when when Stewart was hosting The Daily
Show and Obama was president the meme
out there on all of mainstream media
every article that was written about
Daily Show was more young people get
their news from The Daily Show than from
CNN New York Times is there for me to
have it both ways
but it's true luck even here in
Australia we have I don't know if you I
don't know if you were experienced in
the project I don't know
I'm gonna see when you guys were here on
the project the project is a saying is
it's meant to be you know a lot and it
does reach the younger people and it's
it's just not funny to take people out
of context to ruin people's lives it's
wrong okay so now you get on a plane you
so the video goes viral everybody's
seeing this you're getting you're
getting retweeted I think by by all the
people that I know really try to push
back against this this man's creamy
daeun nonsense and you know I I didn't
know who you were before so I I watched
it and I was like all right this this is
legit like I'm watching I didn't hey I
know you know I know you know you know
but you know I've seen this game before
so I was I was more than happy to just
spread awareness about this okay so then
you reach out and you say well I think
maybe I reached out to you first and I
said you know if you want to come in
studio let's make this happen
yeah within a day you were like all
right I'm coming to the States
so what inspired me to come when you
said when we have we start the
conversation but I said you know what
and I spoke to Sidney Watson who's a
good friend here he's very promising you
know she's a Sky News contributor she
has her own following and she was like
yeah let's do it she's hot she's a dual
citizen American struck and we said
let's do this let's go you know we
already have something we have something
in place we're gonna go I'm Reuben and
we're gonna go you know my idea was to
go to Comedy Central just walk in the
door you know talk to somebody with the
Comedy Central logo on a mama you know
anyone can watch any of my content I
when I'm asked to leave I leave but
that's good enough for me I'll walk into
Comedy Central and if I bring up some
content that you've got and you asked me
to leave that's telling that's enough
visual that somebody in Comedy Central
religion you know right now that's been
my problem he's no one even wants to
respond the same producer that was so
open to talking to me before he's not
responding to my whatsapp messages
anymore that's what's so interesting to
me it's like they don't even understand
the internet game that they think that
they're part of like they think that if
you just ignore this long enough that
it's going to go away but I mean they're
they're messing with the wrong
walking here there's two people they
need to talk to I can talk to my mum
asked her how persistent I am I'm a pain
in their ass to speak to my officer in
the army look join the IDF to be on the
frontline begin a specific unit and I
got there like I'm gonna go till they
respond and they need to know that so we
decided to do this we call it the
American tour against breaking news we
were going to come to you on your show a
few other shows it organized and it was
just growing it was you in the beginning
and we just thought were build around
that well I was gonna go to his Jim
Jefferies show in Maryland see if I can
actually engage him man I was going to
talk to just even the people lining up
in the audience now I want to make it
clear I was going to do it not in a
threatening manner I'm tiny look I'm a
little guy and you can see I go into
some places and you know online you see
everyone's a lot bigger than me
generally I'm the smallest buy in the
room I'm not very threatening and I'm
willing to talk to anybody and only talk
I only ever talk so there's no basis for
any perceived real threat but when we
got to the state it was myself and
Sidney sin he's even Sydney's bigger
than me but she's with her America she's
but our American thing so we split up
straight away I've gone into the line
now as soon as I've come through the to
the immigration desk the something's
obviously popped up on his screen as
soon as he's what my passport and he
goes I need to come with me we need
updates and details about your about
your I think it's called estimating like
the visa waiver program that we have
here with us try so I'm fine
at this point I still think it's okay
the acting quite normal takes me into a
back room a superior officer he's there
and I found it interesting because he
kind of seemed like he knew my name
already and he was expecting me but I
went with the flow they've taken me
around in LAX to an area where it's more
cluded they put your bags on the thing
he's be going through my bags checking
if I got over $10,000 I wish I did
they're asking what I'm doing here and
it's all still raisin well I'm starting
to get a little bit more suspicious
they've written down about stuff and
then they go okay we just got we've got
a few more questions no go sit in this
room and talk about it I knew it's on
they open the door to this bathroom
there's two FBI agents you know there's
a man in a suit and then a woman behind
a computer and they've shown their ID
ago FBI look I saw that and I just
cracked up laughing I looked at him and
I'll just go Comedy Central and but the
the agent tells me goes we are actually
a separate entity to Comedy Central like
he had to say that going we'll but
Comedy Central is the informant yeah and
he's just responded straight away and
this is when people ask me how do you
know it's comedy says well he's gone he
said to me literally we've received a
number of complaints from Comedy Central
about certain things that we just want
to clarify okay so wait we got a really
drill this one home that means that
Comedy Central contacted either the FBI
or the TSA or whatever else is going on
there decided it's in the jurisdiction
of FBI because they knew that you were
coming to the United States I guess to
do a couple shows including this one and
you were gonna just talk I know it was
on my website the description of what we
were doing there so we're coming on your
show we're going on steven crowder and
we were gonna go confront exactly so
they've called and they've literally
given screenshots they've taken
screenshots of different posts I've made
including one from a British
Conservative the news site which
how dare they use an image of me as an
IDF soldier with my with my rifle and
they've basically taken everything and
gone through it as in are they training
am i trying to obtain weapons I turned
to my god the only weapons I have that I
need in this tool is my microphone and
my camera that's all and by the end of
it the FBI had cleared me the FBI were
laughing with me about a day actually
said to me I understand why you want to
come and clear your name that's fine
they got they got it though actually
really nice like I have no problem with
them I have no problem with that with
the Border Protection either my problem
here is that Comedy Central who have
been ignoring all of this had the time
to go to the FBI
you know they've gone out of their way
to just silence at first online when all
these people are you know responding
back asking him just to make a statement
they're blocking people by the hundreds
and then on top of that when they hear
I'm coming to the States
they literally contacted the FBI to try
get them to stop me from coming on the
on the premise that I am coming there to
violently assault somebody okay so going
on the assumption you were not here to
violently assault and that the FBI was
on board that and that they accepted
what you were laying out that you were
just here to do interviews and that sort
of thing yeah obviously all true and
calm and the fact that Comedy Central I
mean it really like it shows some other
layer of really perverse collusion
between networks and and the FBI I mean
how insane is that but they they did
catch you on on a technicality related
something from years ago so it's
important I think it's important to talk
about otherwise people are gonna think
whoa the FBI is in on some real
conspiracies no no once that happen it
obviously triggered whatever process the
border protection half which is to go
through everything within your Visa Visa
or Visa Waiver whatever it is that
you're coming in on and what they found
we had a few you know it was over the
interrogation with the FBI was
then there was a couple of other you
know interviews with different Border
Protection with the highest levels in
LAX who actually I'm not gonna hurt
their their jobs but there were actually
really good people I have no problem
with him and I believe in Border
Protection and if somebody that makes a
mistake like what they found so what it
turns out is two years ago when I filled
out this visa waiver application online
which I want to point out I had come
even seven months ago in New York I've
been in the States on the same visa from
that same application so there was no
problem and it was an absolute
technicality so what they found is when
you fill out these B's of waiver forms
online there's a bunch of crazy
questions and you know you just like I'm
I read them I no no no I'm not a
terrorist
I'm not this I'm not a neo-nazi I'm not
there to create violence I've never been
so you just do no no no no one of them
happened to say have you ever been
denied a visa to the US now about 15
years ago I came on a Visa Waiver and
right after I got back to Australia I
applied for a visa they thought that
implied that I was trying to come there
to live so I was trying to immigrate to
the US and I got denied a visa now I I
don't know I don't even remember filling
in the form so I don't know but that
happened and I said that openly to the
the Border Protection Officer that
technicality means that it makes the the
application void enough it means so they
were saying to me look you're not
getting banned there's nothing wrong
it's an accident in fact they they said
to me if we basically investigate the
same way we did your scrutinize every
app every person that comes here on a
Visa Waiver probably half of them will
end up doing a mistake on that
application and they'll be thrown out as
well more you gotta do is go back to
Australia and apply for a busy you can't
use the visa waiver program anymore
you've got to actually have a visa
because you have been denied now
remember this is a technicality on a
technicality because I only got refused
the visa back then because I was trying
to immigrate well in their minds it was
the risk that I was trying to immigrate
to the US now obviously when I was there
seven months ago I didn't immigrate to
the US so even that was wrong but I
accept that ya know I have no problem
with that I'm here I am going to reapply
and if everything they're saying is true
I'm gonna get in because I have no
criminal record I'm not there's no
reason for me not to get the visa my
problem with it all is that practically
on a practical level Comedy Central got
me chica even in the short term even in
the short term they managed to get me
kicked out because the fact that they
were able to go to the FBI and complain
they triggered this investigation they
got me out on a technicality that in
their own words most people or at least
half the people that come into the u.s.
would would fail as well right so the
point here is the point here is that
seven months ago
you got in with no problem and that
Comedy Central then triggers this by
contacting the FBI shows that they have
some level of power even if the agents
are going yeah this is nonsense it was
15 years ago and everyone knows when
you're when you're going you know when
you're landing in another country or
you're filling out these things
sometimes they're written in very
confusing ways where you almost think no
me well yeah they printed it out for me
it was very clean but there are so many
questions and most of them are crazy so
you just kind of do no no no no no in
the time I wouldn't have lied about it
for nothing because I I would have
thought obviously they'll know if I'd
been denied or not it's their it's their
immigration I can't believe I didn't
pick it up automatically yeah so have
you um you know this is a weird thing
that I think the free-speech crew is now
confronted with where you know when
we're the ones that are getting libeled
and slandered all the time and having
reputations destroyed and having media
manipulated and and video edited and all
of these things it's a weird place for
us to be the ones having to
talk about legal remedies but have you
thought about this at all we are at the
moment yes we've got a few things going
on and that we're working we're going to
fight this from a few fronts then my
main objective more than anything is to
get them to face up to what they've done
and to respond and take responsibility
over because it is wrong I don't care if
you're from the left if you from the
right I don't care to do that to do what
they've done and further the injury to
at every point that you have a chance to
stand up and take that responsibility
take and and apologize not only to me
apologize to your to your fans I've seen
so many people and didn't everything
that that I'm actually said I don't even
like avi I don't even like what he
stands for I don't agree with anything
but what you did is wrong
at least give those you know do the
right thing and you know when I was in
the airport I was there always detained
for about 15 hours and the hardest part
for me in that time is besides being
treated like a criminal was the fact
that Sidney Watson was sitting in in in
in the airport lost didn't you know
waiting for we had a flight together to
New York she's just seen there not
knowing what's going on I kept asking
Border Protection if they were informing
her they said yes I've got one phone
call in fact they were good they
actually gave me two phone calls and and
and he let me tweet and she said don't
tweet anything about me brother but the
fact is that you know I was sitting
there going she all right you know it's
a it's a foreign country might have the
American citizenship but she's an Aussie
what friends from he here and we went to
trouble together well we're not crew
I've suddenly been detained she got
questions as well
she was also investigated but they
couldn't do anything she's American so
it was and for her since I've seen on
her you know I didn't even really know
everything she went through till I
watched her YouTube summary of what had
she gone through on that day and it's
it's horrible and it's painful for me to
watch it because it's all comes down
to Comedy Central doing literally trying
to silence us
what's also crazy to me is the the way
that they don't know how this game will
play out it's like if they would have
done well first I'm doing the right
thing would have been not selectively
editing but okay let's say they can't
they can't do it that way because
they're playing a certain game
well then once you call them out on it
you just immediately you know we messed
this one up especially after the
Christchurch thing where where emotions
were so high it's coming off a horrific
horrific horrific tragedy that you had
taped this thing way before I mean there
was a way they could have gotten out you
know we just we just botched this one
that's it but now they've got it to the
point and that's why I wanted to do this
with you where the longer they let this
stew it's not just that at this point
you know in a way Jim Jefferies should
be fired or at least his and I don't
like calling for this kind of stuff this
is so not how I do this but it's like
his executive producer or whoever made
those decisions should be fired but the
longer they go on you're getting this to
the place where you're gonna have to
take out major executives are gonna have
to be fired because somebody is now
making these decisions and the way these
corporations work it's going to be
pretty obvious through emails and
meetings who made the decisions to throw
you under the bus who made the decision
to contact the FBI I'm we're gonna get
we're gonna get to the bottom of all
that we are going to find that at the
end of it because I am persistent like I
said what's bothering me is that the
mainstream media are not talking about
and that is obviously like I said to you
before we came on is that I believe they
think it's a non-story or they're scared
to report on that because suddenly the
camera is gonna be on them because they
all do it and that's why it's so
important I've been like I feel grateful
that people like you and there's been a
few few you know alternative online
media people who actually have integrity
who have had reported on it and they're
as outraged about it as I am
look I'm watching it from the slide like
not even in my if I just saw that from
the side I would be this disgusted
because it is so wrong and I like even
if it was somebody I absolutely disagree
with I would be yeah it was wrong well
that's what I was saying to you before
it's like it's the perfect
of craziness it's media manipulation
it's leftist insanity it's dishonest
hosts its it's all of these thing
everything at once do you remember about
two months ago Allie Stuckey who was
actually on my show last week who's a
conservative podcaster she did a fake
interview with Alexandria Casio Cortez
where they just sliced Ally's questions
with you know and it's like Ally
positive experience and it will go
obvious that it was fake and it was so
obvious that this is exactly what Comedy
Central does all the time and this is
exactly what you know daily show and all
these things do all the time but the
meeting went bananas that it was the
conservatives spreading a fake interview
to make AOC look ridiculous and it's
like guys do this to people on the right
every single day that I choose your
number one motivated person you don't
need to cut anything up to break stupid
yeah exactly
she's doing up she's doing a fine I
actually thought within a day there
would be mainstream media and there's
been a couple like in Australia there's
a for The Daily Telegraph a man called
Tim Blair he's written a few times about
it but you know Channel 10 News in
Australia they they only wrote about it
in the context of me being deported in
fact it was it was a disgusting story at
first then I called her out on Twitter
and within two minutes she called me
back and you know she she in her report
she actually wrote we reached out to our
before comment with no response and it
was like I was in detention how the hell
did you want me to respond you know
they're just so full of it everything
they do everything they do they this is
one of them the hallmarks of what they
do I've had this happen to me many times
though they'll reach out for you to
comment about a half hour before the
article goes up you could be at the
freaking dentist you could be walking
your dog buddy
in our report she was reporting that I
was in detention yes it's like everyone
is they think people are pretty dumb and
I hate to tell you but I can already
predict what's gonna happen here
there'll be a couple with there'll be a
couple of hit pieces about this you'll
be said oh they put you on alright
Rubens show and but I mean the Jewish no
I'm the Jewish Nazi in Australia so I
think you might be the one in for
trouble yeah that's fine listen I've
taken the arrows that that's alright
what do you think this says about the
way this nonsense is spreading across
borders because you know as you know I
was on tour with Peterson for the last
year and we went to a ton of countries
including about ten stops yeah well yeah
and the Australian shows were absolutely
phenomenal I mean just the audiences
were incredible I just love you guys
well there was just such a zest for life
and and fun I went out with audience
members almost every night after the
show I just I seriously just had a had
an absolute blast but but what I'm
amazed by right now after the last year
is that I've seen the way the world
operates online and on Twitter and on
YouTube but then I've traveled the world
and I've been to Sweden into Denmark and
you know Canada and us and and all and
Ireland and all over the place and the
fact that there are people in all of
these places that are you know thousands
of miles away from each other thinking
the same exact things it's pretty
powerful and I think I think that right
there is what these guys fear more than
anything else that there actually is a
worldwide
push back against their nonsense are you
feeling that absolutely and that's
that's what they're shutting people down
while they're trying to you see
personally I've been showing off
Facebook for things that they can't even
they can't even back it they you ask
them for any evidence and they can't
show you what it is exactly and that's
the way that they're trying to silence
you all these different organizations
the fact that the facts again that
commented that within 24 hours month my
video with my whole page would shut down
shows me that there is a collusion there
between Comedy Central and and that's
not some crazy conspiracy theory that
that is just common sense
easy dots to connect there yeah what why
do you think YouTube left the video up
if if Facebook took it down because I'm
sure Qatar will try it on YouTube too
I don't know maybe it's money I don't
know I don't know I don't know why but
you know YouTube I found over the last
year has been better then Facebook well
you know until they get pressured for
example my good friend Tommy Robinson
they pulled his page straight off
Facebook YouTube actually defended
keeping his channel up until a number of
Labour MPs really bullied Facebook into
into they well they didn't want to
backtrack they defended this list as I
said he never breached their terms and
conditions so then they backtracked once
there was about two months of lobbying
I'll call it bullying bullying by Labour
MP in the UK and then suddenly they
didn't want to say they're banning so
they restricted heavily restricted his
channel YouTube I don't I think unless
there is a some political thing that so
far they see I think they're starting to
recognize that you've got you're running
your business into the ground
Facebook is running their business into
the ground and you can see it even just
in their shares but it is a dying thing
what we've all gone to telegram
we've gone to a a lucky it's basically
the whatsapp that's protected not by
Facebook but by Russian - Russian
brothers
and what finding it fantastic you know
the you get the responses so much better
you see the click-through it is
absolutely unbelievable but it is crazy
that were being forced to these other
platforms that are meant to be messaging
apps instead of using actual social
media because these different
organizations in different institutions
have hold so much power yeah we do you
mean that you're actually spreading your
videos through telegram I mean I know
it's Anna I know it's a messaging app
but you're saying you're building an
actual audience there I didn't even know
that was Tommy Robinson news we call it
Tommy Robinson news and your members
join like any page and you you can even
in
like sand things so people can actually
interact it's a one-way war and you can
link out you can do it's so much better
then so you can put we can literally
upload videos there and say ok they're
not letting us put videos on Facebook
but we'll upload it here with a little
download button we don't need our
one-page you guys all have your own
pages you go upload and flood there
there are different platforms with this
content and it is so much more effective
and I think that is going to be the
future to be honest it is that is the
future of social media if they continue
down this path all of them are going to
crash from the Twitter YouTube Facebook
they're all going to crash unless they
allow people to actually have a fair go
is the perverse part of this I always
say that it's like you know if they
would just not be totally horrible we
would all have nothing to talk about
it's like if they were 30% horrible or
like 50% horrible we'd kind of complain
every now and again and people would be
like they're always complaining but then
they do these sorts of things it's like
you guys are it's not that you're just
going all the way harm well it's not
just that you selectively edit and you
manipulate and you throw people under
the bus
and you try to just spread this chill
effect so that because it's not about
destroying you right it's like they know
well if we can destroy a bee it's like
we can take out thousands of other
people that will never speak up again
and it's like man if you guys would just
not be all in on the [ __ ] then we
probably have other things to be talking
about yeah look it absolutely the fact
is I think they thought I was an easy
target now probably a bit like you they
didn't really know who I was they just
knew you know if you look in Australia
I'm probably the biggest name for
alternative media here and that's not
because I'm that great I think I am
media thing here so I think they they
they thought I'd be an easy target they
totally underestimated the fact that I
am NOT an idiot and you know that that
today to fight back is not that hard
because I can say this to people is
actually
I think people are looking for the truth
it's kind of the Trump effect and the
whole idea of fake news you know they
think said Trump is so nuts and he keeps
going on about fake news they literally
create fake news that is actually a
thing and anyone that's had anything to
do with media will know that fake is a
real problem and that's not to say Trump
is the best guy in the world or I'm the
most innocent person in the world but
the fact is that these in these
organizations are corrupt so corrupt and
they act like they are so much better
than that they hold the moral high
ground when they are the biggest scum in
the world they are literally worse than
the worst people you know it's so
strange guy I tweeted something the
other day about it's like Trump for his
orange skin and his hair plugs and the
crazy way he speaks it's like somehow
despite all of that he's more authentic
than them I mean that tells it right
there it's right like this guy looks
fake he doesn't he doesn't look like a
what a regular human being looks like
like that's how fake he looks and and
the way he speaks the whole thing and
yet he can actually come off more
authentic than these people because
they're so polished and they got away
with it for so long they don't even know
how to how to do it right anymore I
think it's the age of the internet where
you know before that we saw something on
TV it was polished it was perfect and
that's what we got you know if we seen
something that was a little bit
unpolished it was kind of a that's
rubbish that's fake that's on now we're
in an age where you know Google Hangouts
you can do a conversation from across
the world even if they deport someone
and you know it's the content it's the
words it's the it's the substance people
are listening to that nobody cares what
something looks like nobody cares even
though he's rough around the edges and
he's not that articulate either nobody
cares because people who like what's he
saying what's he telling me what's he
defending what's he standing up for what
he standing against and I think that's
what shines real I God personally I see
it in myself I look at him and I go I
like that and it's just the bonus
triggers the people I don't lock a lot
no so I have an idea here because
there's no doubt that there are dozens I
have no doubt
dozens of Comedy Central employees and
executives watching this right now
sitting in their cubicles with their
headphones because they don't want
anyone to know that they're watching but
what I find is that over the course of
this show I have found people over the
years
James d'amour Lindsey Shepherd Brett
Weinstein people who have you know taken
unpopular positions or basically stood
up to the mob I would say more than
anything else and they've survived and
you're obviously going to survive this
so why don't you talk directly to the
Comedy Central employees right now the
executives who are gonna have to make
some decisions on that or we got about
eight minutes left I mean let's tell
them what to do we got it that you want
the apology but but if they're there if
they're in the belly of the beast what
do you think they should do get I guys
my name's avi you probably recognize me
from the last two weeks with nights you
know be a person for once you know step
back a second and think about it because
I'm also a person you might not agree
with my positions you might not like
what I have to say you you may you may
really dislike me but what you did was
wrong what you did was fake and you know
it's if anything hopefully you've
learned something hopefully you've just
turned around and looked in the mirror
for a second and gone that that makes me
a bad person like if that was my idea if
I'm the editor whoever it is they're not
also Jim Jefferies I've heard people say
you know excuse me Jim Jefferies he's
not the one that cuts it you know what
he's he certainly seen the final cut
he's also you know had to had to do the
pieces the camera where he knew he was
throwing me under the bus
look at yourself for a second night you
were sitting there acting like you're my
best mate we did a photo after you would
sure you know and there was I walked out
of that that day going maybe this is not
going to end up the way I expected it to
maybe you're actually going to be decent
and when I say decent but just represent
the person you interviewed the person
who flew halfway around the frickin
world to be a part of your little show
just represent me you didn't do that so
now is your chance to do the right thing
and don't even do it because you're
scared of what's to come and I promise
you there's a lot to come but do it
because it is actually a chance to
recognize what you did and there are
millions around the world who are
watching if that's your incentive then
so be it but if it makes you actually
recognizing and become a bigger person
out of it then my job here is done
not bad man some somebody heard that I
guarantee you and that's all it takes is
a little spark with some of these people
to get the inertia going you know well
they often claim to be to work from an
emotional place I'm speaking to them
right now on an emotional level because
you know it I'm grateful I could not
imagine where I would be emotionally
where would I be as a person emotionally
if what was put out was just their
version of events
no well your career would be over
basically not even my career my mental
yeah I don't think there's anything
worse then you know being blamed for
something you didn't do
knowing like seeing what they produced
and knowing the truth me knowing only me
know and me not being able to prove it
to anyone I couldn't imagine that I just
and I consider myself a pretty strong
person like mentally strong and I've
been through a lot in my life I don't
know if I would have survived that and
that you know they talk about they often
talk about people you know pushing
people over the edge because how dare
you criticize a religion or criticize
ideas or say something against
transgender or gay marriage because
you're gonna ruin people's psychology
you know what were you gonna do to me
what were you going to do to another
human being
is it gonna take you to get back into
the states do they tell you once you
fill out all this stuff great people
reach out to me already you know from I
don't want to highlighting they have a
people who wield power in the u.s. I
don't think it's gonna be too much of an
issue and as Annie would say I would be
back I think I think we hit the main
points here hopefully in it yeah
hopefully this does a little something I
mean just this army you know what I will
ask you one other thing actually before
we wrap up so I find a me judging me not
only for my accent but for the way I'm
stringing my sentences together no it's
- I am alright we got all right you got
to get to bed so I'll just ask you one
other thing then which is where do you
think you know I know you're not going
to view it this way because I asked this
question to a lot of people and they
never accept the premise but where do
you think the bravery comes from within
you that you're willing to fight this
because because everyone that I know
that is stood up to the mob has survived
and not only has survived has actually
thrive Thrawn yeah when I go out when I
go out to colleges when I do speaking
gigs the number one thing I get from
people is I'm afraid they're afraid to
lose their job they're afraid to lose
family members they're afraid to lose
friends etc etc so so where do you think
it comes from within you bravery to
think of it as stupidity I'll leave you
with one story that pretty much sums it
up for me it actually it's kind of how I
feel every day when I served in the
Israeli army I was in a we were we were
ambushed
I had an Arab really good friend of
money is an Arab officer a Christian
officer and this just describes exactly
how I feel every single day and he says
so we were ambushed from in front we
were actually leaving the Gaza Strip
from him front from about five meters in
treated as a five terrorists and from
behind but they were in long-range
artillery they were firing from two
sides now there was about 18 probably in
the class
my gun and it was an American m4 I'm not
let us wear on this show so I'm not
gonna say us we're all your age and so I
was basically standing on the scene on
these June jumping from side to side
just dodging bullets
now at the end of the the chopper had
come and I thought that was the end that
night like I don't really believe in God
really I'm a proud you but that's a
separate story that's a whole other show
you know it's a Tafari
and and finally things have settled and
two of my friends had been hit I was a
marksman now there's two marksmen in
every class when you're going to combat
the the marksman at the front there's
one of the front one in the in the
middle the marksman at the front was hit
so my officer who didn't know my gun and
jammed had called me said Abby because
you've got to go around to the to the
bodies to make sure because obviously a
lot of time they detonate as you walk or
whatever it is so just to make sure the
bodies and that they're actually dead
and he calls me over and this is my
answer to you as you as we're walking
around to the body bodies I've said to
the officer duty mine just so you know I
have no gun I had the scopes the reason
why they take the mark is because I had
the night vision and all that I I come
around coming around and it just mean
hear me I said to him I have no gun
because what do you mean you have no gun
I said him my guns jammed and he's he's
an Arab so he starts cursing me now
every can telling me to get back to the
liar but now after all that we got out
he till today thinks I deserve a medal
for that stupidity and I can't convince
him I've said to him and I'm telling you
genuinely I have never been more [ __ ]
scared in my life
I think I actually crapped myself that
night but he it was the order and it was
just the job needs to be done and that's
what I feel like I'm you know so often
now I don't know what I'm
going into I don't know you know if if
you tell me to go back to the days where
I just owned gyms and just focused on
you know my life then would I go back
it's a tough question I don't want to
think about it because some day is some
days you're in battles that you feel are
overwhelming weight if I don't do it who
will I think the moral of the story is
everyone should have an Arab Christian
yelling at them listen I hope I hope
we've moved the dial for you a little
bit here I look forward to getting into
the states so that you can sit in the
seat right across from me and I could
shake your hand and good luck with
everything and and Jeffries you're
welcome here too I'll gladly be a
peacemaker we got an extra chair so
let's see if we can do that how about I
reckon we should sit together have a
coffee and talk this one out hey Jimmy
boy yes well how the Foresters night
you've been saying those means but I've
seen it I've seen them yep they're great
all right all right